you guys met obviously in lost boys
right we did yeah did you meet like in
how did you meet do you remember the day
you met i i don't
specifically remember the day i know it
was up in
we shot the film in two places we shot
it in los angeles and we shot it in
santa cruz in the very very beginning
and
and in santa cruz it felt very
disjointed
uh there were two units uh it didn't
feel as
cohesive an experience for me at least
uh when we got back to los angeles so i
know
kind of when i met jason it was like hi
this is jason he's playing
and it's like hello and here's your mark
and hey
well nice really nice meeting you man
i'm i'm thrilled to be working with you
okay
and look over there and okay rolling
just like that
it was kind of like that and i remember
we became
he's looking at like well i remembered a
little differently remember well
he's right in that it was disjointed and
it really probably was just a
handshake hello but i do remember that
i actually had my birthday up there
because my birthday is on june 17th and
i turned 20
and they'd made me a cake uh i guess it
was me on a motorcycle or something like
that
and everyone said happy birthday and all
that and i specifically remember
kiefer coming up and taking the knife
and just cutting my head off for his
piece of the cake
taking a walk away now that was before
we worked together
and then the first day that we actually
work together is the first day those
characters meet in the film
yeah yeah on the motorcycle yes did you
hit it off right away or was there you
know there's always that thing i hope
this guy's cool i hope he's not
a hot head he's into that by the end of
that night i think
yeah i think so too i mean at night i
really appreciated the fact
when i first read the script of lost
boys um
you know i came from the world of
get whatever job you can and just deal
with it later
right uh but lost boys was written for
much younger characters
uh they weren't supposed to be in their
20s they were all supposed to be kind of
peter panish 13 12 13 year olds
and and joel had made the change
that he wanted it to be kind of 20 kind
of early 20s
and and stuff like that and so a lot of
the dialogue had to change and i really
appreciated
how seriously jason
took it you know that he was there to
try and make the best film he could
this wasn't i need this much money to
get me to my next job
this was how do we make this really cool
and special and so
he did a lot of you know joel schumacher
who uh
we both kind of love and adored but he
did a lot of the battling with joel
uh kind of on behalf of the rest of us
to make
the script what it ultimately became and
and and
justifying certain actions for our
characters etc etc and so
i really appreciated that he took the
lead on that and that he was kind of an
adult
serious actor uh because a lot of the
stuff that i had done i'd done with very
young people like
stand by me was with 11 12 year olds who
were amazing
by the way and they were fantastic and
you were young too
i was 18 19 yeah yeah i was a year i was
a year younger than jason
and so you guys would get uh as a as a
collective
you and amy amy gertz jamie jamie
jamie gerths yeah me you know i
make mistakes
but you guys would all get together and
go this this this and you'd be the guy
the point man
to sort of talk to joel about it i think
sometimes but it was more that
i spent a lot of time with joel because
he tried to get me the movie for a long
time
and once we started going because i had
a lot to do
it was always about the peace whoever
else was in it
so if i felt that there was an issue
that it wasn't quite working it was more
going to jameer going to kiefer and said
what do you feel about this
or this i would never speak for them and
then
then i would take the lead and go in
there and say look
you know and i gotta say look lost boys
has lost boys because of joel
now i'm not and when i say that i mean
he got the guy
who shot raging bull and taxi driver
michael chapman
you know that guy doesn't come off that
and shoot teen vampire movies but joel
got him
he got bo welch was an amazing
production designer
and then he got all these actors he get
diane wiest right off an oscar
ed herman bernard hughes you know and
young guys like me and kiefer
um so and he would be open to those
ideas
and open to dialogue and to make it
interesting and different i think the
reason the movie has lasted is because
of that effort and because of the
involvement of the people that he picked
and our relationship as adversaries
grew but as i said after that first
night we were thick pals for the next
did you guys go out a lot did you party
we used to go out they'd go out for
lunch and our makeup
you got to tell that story makeup we're
we're sitting here
driving off the warner brothers a lot in
his convertible
no porsche and it's
oh yeah oh it wasn't it was an old 1970
911 tea it was an old old porsche
um and and we were in full vampire
makeup but we had
we just couldn't have any more of the
catering lunch and we just wanted to go
get a burger or something and so we
pulled out
who's with you me just me and jason just
to you yeah in full vampire makeup
and these girls pulled up and i guess
we've been like
we've been wearing the makeup so long
that we forgot it was on yeah we
couldn't see it in each other and the
two girls in the car next to us we were
like hey how you doing and they
just looked they did not appreciate it
as they call this a variety of names and
squealed out literally the light turns
green we're looking over
it's 19 year olds in the porsche and
everything and right when the light
turned greens they just look at us and
say
pigs pigs yeah and drove right off yeah
perfect yeah that's a perfect day it's a
perfect lunch